[Applaudissements]
tu restes angoissant
pour faire comme le monsieur
il a pas de slips
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors
faut pas en faire trop
mal
aux pieds
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
donne-moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec la carte Vitale
quand tu rentres chez toi t'appelle pas
uber mais une ambulance
c'est parti de ces chaussures elles sont
magnifiques
[Rires]
parce que moi j'ai adoré faire du des
tubes frères et moi je vais utiliser un
pote est-ce que tu préfères avoir toute
ta vie tu as une crotte de Zen ici quand
même tu peux pas l'enlever ça veut dire
même quand elle passe au-dessus de la
station
ou bien on tapait cool les bouts et tu
es obligé de mettre des sandales tout le
temps même en hiver
le truc où les homogène
on peut éviter les deux beugène voilà la
crotte de zen c'est quand même relou et
tout le temps avec une meuf et là tu
viens chercher la meuf le premier soir
et commence elle t'a pas encore eu salut
je t'expliquerai là non mais c'est vrai
ça ou les pieds
et sinon
c'est pas mal toi
[Rires]
comme ça à la piscine évidemment
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes très beau à la télé aussi
vous sentez bon
d'autres vous passez votre temps à vous
sniffer l'un l'autre parce que vous avez
dit aussi qu'elle sentait bon et
inversement
inquiète pas inquiète pas on va kiffer
on sera à côté de l'hôpital l'embrasse
point
[Rires]
ça va être génial vas-y ma chérie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous voulez pas le faire vous Siri
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
où tu l'as vu où tu l'avais faire ça
non mais tout le temps comme ça
il m'aide à faire
tout le monde devient fou ici
[Rires]
franchement la meilleure pour moi
c'était Daniel
il bouge tout du pied face
j'en profite tant que je parle
il est là pour toi qui a le mieux danser
bah je sais pas je vous ai pas vu
[Applaudissements]
son beau papa
je crois pas qu'il soit français